it's been a beautiful day in new york
and the mets are hoping to make it a
perfect day tonight for their second
doubleheader sweep of the season joey
lukasic he has faced the rockies a lot
in his career as you'd imagine garrett
hamson will lead off hampton one for
nine in this series taking outside so
leadoff walk for hampton
trevor's story taking ball four
back-to-back walks for the rockies they
are stacking two quality of bats against
luke casey
line caught toward a second hamson gets
back hamson takes off swung and missed
throw to third by mccann and they pull
off the double steal
krone strikes out for the second out but
hampson steals third and story follows
him to second
3-2 and rogers slams it out to right
back toward the corner goes mckinney and
he makes the catch
billy mckay got a very nice jump on that
ball going toward the right field corner
and he reels it in to save luke casey a
couple of runs antonio senzutela he is
the guy
going to work for the rockies now but he
issues a lead off walk so each pitcher
walks the first man they face
and here is lindor now all for his last
16. lendura lines run the other way past
the global story he's got a base in if
the yard turns second he's going to try
for third and joe will not have a play
on him
so lindor snaps his own for 16 and vr
hustles his way to third
well story was looking like he was going
to break lindor's heart again
just past them beat him to left field
nice job by vr
one little story tipped that ball but it
never got all the way
to connor joe yes just off the end of
the glove so it deadened it
and that allowed vr
who's been proved to be
very enigmatic base runner but very fast
and takes advantage
so first and third and nobody out now
billy mckinney who made his mets debut
in the opener today mckinney hits a
double play ball rogers to story and on
to first as a run comes home and it's
one nothing new york four six three
double play no rbi for mckinney but he
makes contact to make sure the mints get
a run so the mets who won the first game
one nothing now lead the nightcap maybe
add to it 2-2
swinging a ground ball right side
backhanded by rogers sidearm flip to
first they get smith
it ends the inning the mets get a run
more than worrying about him re-injuring
it roll to the right side and peraza in
front of it throws out diaz and it's a
one two three inning for luke casey
after getting the lead he throws a
shutdown one nothing meant pete alonso
at first base
pitch is bounced right back to
senzatella off the bout of perazi flips
it underhand to cj crone
real nice second inning for senza
story deep to right field that goes
mckinney to the warning track right at
the wall to make the catch
two long fly balls both caught on the
warning track and lucas who survives the
third
this is grounded up the middle when you
break the streak story spins and fires
out at first
cj crone
what a pick
obviously great play by trevor story as
well cameron mavin's had enough
he said uncle and just went back to the
dugout ground ball
trevor makes a great spinning throw on
target
cj krohn with the pick
see the subaru super mode the little
pirouette picks up the target
delivers a strike
with what's happening with cameron for
24.
i just don't have time to get to it
vr's wasting no time he's heading
towards second base a throw
got him
connor joe in left field guns down vr
to put runners at first and second with
two outs and connor joe do up field
george smith comes in one two pitch
ground ball that's gonna get through
into right center field for a base hit
cj crone around third he will score
connor joe with the rbi single and he
ties the game at one connor joe drive it
right through the right side of the
infield jonathan dazza
rounding second base here's cj crone
cutting the pillow at third scoring the
rockies first run to tie it up
and diaz flies one out to right mckinney
coming in and toward the line he'll get
there
and slides to make the catch
billy mckinney's looked impressive in
right field in this doubleheader trevor
story was pulled because of arm
tightness
now in center field the bases are loaded
second walk of the game issued by
senzatella so a double a hit by pitch in
a walk have loaded them up for patrick
mazzeka runners off their bases the
pitch from senzatella called strike
three
mazika hot as he heads back to the
dugout that pitch at the knees for out
number two so it's left to jose peraza
with the bases loaded and two out peraza
delivered a home run in the opener for
the game's only run and he hits this one
toward the hole that's a base hit
mckinney is in dumb stops at third the
ball bobbled in left field by joe but
dom had already put on the brakes the
mets take the lead
harazza got his home run on the first
pitch in the first game he jumps on the
first pitch here and finds a hole to put
the mets in front two to one looks like
fastball up and in
frost was ready for it found the spot
between mcmahon and rogers okay for a
sweep of this double header they lead
the nightcap 2-1 with two innings left
to play jerry's familia will pitch the
six one-two coming struck him out
that is some kind of sinker from familia
to get dazzer for the second half ball
came back end down both rogers still at
first and now connor joe has had himself
a good game
and joe pulls one on the ground to vr
comes up nicely for him and that retires
the side
good inning for a familiar one lead
going to the bottom of the sixth in a
seven inning game in the nightcap and 26
year old jordan sheffield is on to pitch
for the rockies the bases are loaded man
of the hour is going to be coming to the
plate jose peraza
and that's ball four and that'll force
in a run they now lead this game three
to one cameron maven now
mounted left side off the glove at
mcmahon towards home
he got him out at home
how unbelievable play five six
two
fielders choice
over 26 cameron mabel
unbelievable play by the rockies defense
right there
the field awareness by brendan rodgers
is really really good right here
here's drury as a pinch hitter with the
bases load with three and two and two
down and drury checks his swing ball
four and it forces in another run
the second bases loaded walk of the
enemy
robert gazellman who hasn't had a save
since 2019 will bid for one today one
more out to get for gazellman and it's
rymel topia
this one's pulled to right field that'll
fall for a hit for tapia blackman will
come around to score 4-2 rockies
and with two outs mcmahon will come to
the plate as the tying run yes jacob
barnes up in the bullpen not and he's
making the call 1-1 to mcmahon top of
your runs mcmahon flies it to left
mckinney is there
and the ball game is over
barnes comes in to get the final out of
the game
the mets sweep the doubleheader and take
three out of four from the rocky